- This extraordinary year
has shown us that wherever we step back,
the space we leave
is providing wildlife
with new opportunities.
[sweeping orchestral music]
- This pandemic can help us
take a step back
and assess the relationship
that humans want to have
with the natural world.
Juneau is a premier
whale watching destination.
In a typical year, we'll have
about 1.3 million people
visit by cruise ship.
And of those, a quarter of them
will board smaller boats
to go on whale watching trips.
This year, we essentially have zero.
This year is
a really incredible opportunity
as a scientist
to collect data in the absence
of a lot of boats on the water,
that we can then compare
to previous and future years
of normal whale watching activity.
- The number of whale watching boats
around a whale
increases the amount of sound
that a whale is exposed to.
Therefore, there's the potential
for whales to be more stressed out
than they would if they had
less disturbance around them.
- The goal of the study is to determine
what is the stress hormone level
of these whales
during this unusual year.
- What we're looking for
is the concentration
of a steroid hormone called cortisol,
and we recognize this as stress.
Power two, safety off.
Let's try and get a little bit closer.
- When we're collecting our data,
we believe we have
a fairly minimal impact on the whale,
so the biopsy samples
that we take--
I would compare that
to getting a finger prick
at the doctor's office,
so it hurts
for just a split second,
but then, after that, you're fine,
and you forget about it.
- We fire this towards the animal.
It hits into the side of the animal,
and then it bounces off
and floats in the water.
- It's leaking blubber.
- And when we get it, we have
skin and blubber
in this coring end.
Okay, so I'll just hold on to it.
You twist.
It's a pretty small sample.
It's a little smaller
than the eraser end of a pencil.
Think we got it all.
Nice job.
- All right, good sample.
Our results might help to inform
management, regulations, and guidelines
for humpback whales in Juneau,
so perhaps changes
to the number of boats around whales,
how long boats stay with whales,
and overall, how many boats
are on the water.
This moment provides
a really unique opportunity
to understand the natural state
of whales and other wildlife
around the globe.
- We have an opportunity
to slow down a little bit
and think about how we interact
with wildlife
and what that might look like
with a little bit more intention.
[gentle music]